let's get some more practice doing
implicit differentiation so let's find
the derivative of Y with respect to X
we're going to assume that Y is a
function of X so let's apply our
derivative operator to both sides of
this equation so let's apply our
derivative operator and so first on the
left hand side we essentially are just
going to apply the chain rule first we
have some the derivative of the
derivative with respect to X of x minus
y squared so the chain rule tells us
this is going to be the derivative of
the something squared with respect to
the something which is just going to be
two times X minus y to the first power I
won't leave I won't write the one right
over there times the derivative of the
something with respect to X well the
derivative of X with respect to X is
just 1 and the derivative of Y with
respect to X that's what we're trying to
solve so it's going to be 1 minus dy 1
minus dy DX let me make it a little bit
clearer what I just did right over here
this right over here is the derivative
of X minus y X minus y squared with
respect to X minus y with respect to X
minus y and then this right over here is
the derivative of X minus y with respect
with respect to X just the chain rule
now let's go to the right-hand side of
this equation this is going to be equal
to the derivative of X with respect to X
is 1 the derivative of Y with respect to
X we're going to write that as the
derivative of Y with respect to X and
then finally the derivative with respect
to X of a constant that's just going to
be equal to 0
now let's if we can solve for if we can
solve for the derivative of Y the
derivative of Y with respect to X so the
most obvious thing to do let's make it
clear this right over here I can rewrite
as 2x minus 2y so let me do that so I
can save some space this is 2x minus 2y
if I just distribute the 2 and now I can
distribute the 2x minus 2i onto each of
these terms so 2x minus 2y times 1 is
just going to be
to X minus 2y and then to X minus 2y
times negative dy/dx that's just going
to be negative 2x minus 2i or we could
write that as 2 y minus 2 x times dy DX
times dy/dx is equal to 1 plus dy DX is
equal to 1 plus I'll do all my dy/dx is
in orange now 1 plus dy DX so now
there's a couple of things that we could
attempt to do we could subtract 2x minus
2y from both sides so let's do that so
let's subtract 2x minus 2y from both
sides so over here we're going to
subtract minus we're going to subtract
2x minus 2y from that side and then we
could also subtract a dy/dx from both
sides so that all of our dy DX's are on
the left-hand side and all of our non dy
DX's are on the right-hand side so let's
do that so we're going to subtract a DUI
DX on the right and a and a dy/dx here
on the left and so what are we left with
what are we left with well on the
left-hand side these cancel out and
we're left with 2y minus 2x dy/dx minus
1 dy DX or just minus the dy DX let me
make it clear we could write this as a
minus 1 dy DX so this is we can
essentially just add these two
coefficients so this simplifies to 2y
minus 2x minus 1 times the derivative of
Y with respect to X the derivative of Y
with respect to X which is going to be
equal to on this side this cancels out
we are left with 1 minus 2x plus 2y so
let me write it that way or we could
write this as we could write this as so
negative negative 2y is just a positive
2y and then we have minus 2x and then we
add that one plus 1 and now to solve for
dy do
X we just have to divide both sides by 2
i minus 2x minus 1 and we are left with
we deserve a little bit of a drumroll at
this point as you can see the hardest
part was really the algebra to solve for
dy/dx we get the derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to 2y minus 2x
plus 1 over 2y minus 2x minus 1